[Música]
hola a todos bienvenidos a los
observadores de france 24 esta semana
veremos una escena de humillación
pública llevada a cabo por la policía de
teherán a principios del mes de octubre
luego veremos cómo se comunican los
manifestantes en tailandia durante las
manifestaciones contra la monarquía y
terminaremos con la noticia falsa de la
semana acerca de las teorías de
conspiración sobre el 19
[Aplausos]
[Música]
esta impactante escena ocurrió en
teherán el 7 de octubre cuando la
policía y huyó públicamente a presuntos
criminales esta es la cuarta vez en
menos de un mes que una escena de este
tipo se produce en el país nuestra
observadora hacia a mí es una periodista
iraní especializada en temas sociales
sería está radicada en noruega y desde
hace varios años se interesa por hechos
como estos desfiles de la vergüenza
en muchos los 20 minutos te va mucho más
sana más jazz un rumor
wyndham y este tipo de castigo ha
existido durante unos 40 años y empezó
con la revolución iraní a veces estas
humillaciones son organizadas
directamente por la policía iraní pero
otras veces son dictadas por un juez
pero si miramos la ley iraní no hay
ningún elemento que autorice castigar
con estos humillantes desfiles como los
que vemos en estos vídeos los que se
enfrentan a tal castigo nunca vuelven a
tener una vida social normal
es imposible cuando uno ha sido
humillado de esta manera más allá de eso
es una tortura tanto psicológica como
física la brecha entre los ciudadanos y
el estado nunca ha sido tan grande cada
vez hay más manifestaciones para
protestar contra la situación económica
pero también política y la gente muestra
su descontento públicamente cada vez más
parecería que el miedo a los
levantamientos está empujando al estado
iraní a utilizar métodos para
aterrorizar al pueblo para silenciarlo y
evitar nuevas manifestaciones
y tras las numerosas reacciones a este
vídeo en el que presuntos criminales son
humillados el jefe del sistema judicial
iraní condenó a estos actos llevados a
cabo sin ningún tipo de juicio
[Aplausos]
miles de manifestantes en tailandia han
estado pidiendo reformas democráticas y
oponiéndose a la monarquía durante
semanas comunicarse en medio de la
multitud es primordial y estos
manifestantes han desarrollado su propio
lenguaje
durante las manifestaciones en las señas
con las manos o son muy importantes para
comunicarse por ejemplo si alguien
quiere un casco para protegerse de un
cañón de agua hace esta señal o si uno
quiere unas gafas plásticas hace esta
señal y más de cuatro mil familias
partes
[Aplausos]
y también usamos frases cortas para
comunicarnos por ejemplo si llega la
policía gritamos esclavos de la tiranía
y así les advertimos a todos
el gesto más simbólico de los
manifestantes es el de los tres dedos
una referencia a las películas de los
juegos del hambre' y una burla a la
monarquía
[Música]
la primera vez que los tailandeses
usaron el gesto de los tres dedos fue en
café en 2014 hubo un golpe de estado en
tailandia y tenemos un gobierno militar
desde hace seis años claro la gente
eligió el saludo de los tres dedos
porque la protagonista
hackett satin iceberg y si también lucha
contra un régimen autoritario muchos de
los que hicieron este saludo fueron
arrestados entonces la gente siente que
puede identificarse a la lucha de karni
su pib white de henry ley demasiados
judy fired carnets
y terminamos con la noticia falsa de la
semana que podrá encontrar en el
instagram de france 24 y en nuestras
redes sociales aceptación donde se le
dio
los expertos predicen que para el año
2020 un nuevo virus llegará si prepara
de algún lugar de asia hacia el resto
del mundo estas dos publicaciones
pretenden mostrar las predicciones
hechas hace más de 50 años las cuales
anunciaban la pandemia de kobe 19 y las
consecuencias para nuestra sociedad
incluso se ven individuos encerrados en
una burbuja protectora el problema es
que estos dos elementos fueron sacados
de su contexto comencemos con la
ilustración una búsqueda de imágenes
inversa nos permitió encontrar la imagen
original publicada en 1962 en el
periódico italiano
doménica del corriere pero si se lee el
pie de foto de la imagen no se hace
ninguna referencia al 2022
el autor simplemente se imagina la
ciudad del futuro y se pregunta si la
gente conducir aún sin goleta un auto
individual imaginario y nada que ver con
la pandemia de joven 19 ahora el
documental en blanco y negro es de hecho
un conjunto de varios vídeos que no
tienen nada que ver entre sí por ejemplo
este extracto tal vez lo peor de todo
será la emergencia de una enfermedad
mortal y potencialmente devastadora
en este clip proviene de un banco de
imágenes en línea que cualquiera puede
comprar se añadió en el vídeo con otros
extractos en particular de una película
de 1940 contactamos al autor del vídeo
original se trata de un vídeo satírico
que imita los códigos de un viejo
reportaje lo publicó el 21 de febrero de
2020 en youtube el vídeo fue sacado de
contexto por los internautas para hacer
creer que se trataba de una predicción
este contenido fue creado ante todo para
entretener y en segundo lugar para
provocar una reflexión entre los
internautas
las versiones virales de este vídeo han
sido modificadas para eliminar el tono
humorístico lo que claramente
distorsionó mi trabajo para resumir
tengan cuidado con las publicaciones que
dicen mostrar predicciones sobre el kobe
19 en los dos casos se trataba o bien de
publicaciones reales pero sacadas de
contexto o de vídeos satíricos
modificados para desinformar
hasta aquí los observadores por esta
semana no dude en escribirnos enviarnos
fotos y videos a los contactos que
aparecen en pantalla gracias a todos
nuestros observadores por sus historias
hasta pronto
[Música]